[Música]
hace dos años china alertó a la
organización mundial de la salud sobre
una neumonía viral que luego sería
reconocida como kobe de 19
el organismo dice que las variantes de
alta y omicron crean un tsunami de
positivos
en llamada telefónica los presidentes de
eeuu y rusia hablarán este jueves de la
creciente tensión en ucrania joe biden
está preocupado por la presencia de
tropas rusas en la zona limítrofe y
vladimir putin exige garantías de
seguridad a occidente
en hong kong cientos de policías
allanaron el medio online prodemocracia
stent news seis personas fueron
arrestadas por conspiración para hacer
publicaciones sediciosas esta es la
página más destacada de las que aún
critican en la china continental
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda
daniela blanton iniciamos hablando de
kobe de 19 porque se cumplen 2 años
desde que en 2019 en la víspera del año
nuevo china alertó a la organización
mundial de la salud sobre una veintena
de casos de una extraña neumonía que
luego sería el kobe de 19 dos años
después el director del organismo
asegura que la circulación simultánea de
las variantes de alta y omicron está
creando un tsunami de casos
mientras la mayor parte del planeta
celebraba el fin del 2019 una nueva
amenaza de energía el 31 de diciembre de
2019 china alertó a la organización
mundial de la salud de 27 casos de una
neumonía viral de origen desconocido
identificados en la ciudad de wuhan lo
que semanas más tarde sería catalogado
como el zarco 2 virus que produce el
kobe 19 oficialmente el primer caso de
la gripe de wuhan fuera de china se
registró en tailandia el 13 de enero de
2020 y rápidamente se extendió por todo
el mundo
el desarrollo y distribución de una
vacuna dividió la opinión pública siendo
la o ms principal promotor de la
inoculación pese a que más de 9 mil
millones de dosis se han administrado
mundialmente en un año las autoridades
sanitarias se lamentan no haber
alcanzado las metas propuestas alcohol
on leaders of reach countries and
manufacturers hago un llamado a los
líderes de cada país ya los fabricantes
para que aprendan las lecciones de alfa
beta gamma delta y ahora omicron y
trabajen juntos para alcanzar el 70 por
ciento de cobertura de vacunación de ses
the time este es el momento de
levantarse del cortoplacismo y proteger
a las poblaciones y las economías contra
futuras variantes game future behrends
con la llegada de omikron y cumpliéndose
el segundo aniversario desde la
aparición del cob y países como francia
a estados unidos e india registran
cifras récord de contagios aunque no de
muerte sobre su educación 15 pm decirle
a los que no sean vacunados hay pocas
posibilidades de que puedan escapar esta
vez el virus se está extendiendo con
demasiada fuerza y los más propensos a
contraer el virus y desarrollar formas
sintomáticas y graves son los que no se
han vacunado una vez que las mascarillas
y el testeo ya son un denominador de
todo el mundo la oms se confía en que el
2022 ponga fin a la fase aguda de la
pandemia
seguimos hablando de la pandemia en
europa porque en francia dos ciudadanos
son diagnosticados con kobe de 19 cada
segundo según el ministerio de salud el
país ha estado batiendo máximos
continuamente de los últimos días y
contabilizó en la última jornada 208 mil
nuevos casos que marcaron no solamente
un nuevo récord nacional sino europeo
actualmente los hospitales están en
límites preocupantes con ingresos por la
variante del talla y expectativas sobre
los efectos de la recién descubierta
omicron españa por su parte redujo el
periodo de aislamiento de 10 a 7 días
para quienes resulten positivos por kobe
19 pero sean asintomáticos o presenten
un cuadro leve de la enfermedad a medida
que la falta de personal debido a los
largos aislamientos causa interrupciones
en algunas industrias el país ibérico
sigue así los pasos de otras naciones
como reino unido y eeuu pese a que viene
registrando un récord de contagios y
este miércoles superó la barrera de los
100 mil
y grecia anunció que desde este jueves
entrarán en vigencia nuevas
restricciones tras de registrar un
récord diario del 28 1828 contagios los
bares discotecas y restaurantes tendrán
que cerrar a la media noche y no podrán
atender a clientes de pie ni tener
música solo en la víspera de año nuevo
podrán permanecer abiertos hasta las 2
de la mañana
cambiamos de continente en colombia a la
corte constitucional ordenó restituir
los derechos a siete inmigrantes
venezolanos que fueron expulsados
arbitrariamente del país durante el paro
nacional de 2019 según el alto tribunal
tras ser detenidos ilegalmente por la
policía su proceso se adelantó de manera
indebida por migración colombia
atentando contra su dignidad humana
consultamos sobre el tema a lucía
ramírez bolívar coordinadora de
investigaciones sobre migración en la
ong de justicia y eso nos dijo
este caso llega a la corte porque estas
siete personas con el acompañamiento de
la clínica jurídica de la universidad de
los andes presentaron una tutela que fue
negada en primera y segunda instancia
pero fue seleccionada por la corte
constitucional lo de prueba que también
se solicitará formalmente que la
selección hará la corte entonces revisó
este caso y como tú decías consideró que
en el procedimiento de expulsión se
vulneraron las garantías al debido
proceso el derecho a la dignidad humana
y a la unidad familiar y entonces le
ordenó tomar medidas muy concretas en
este caso la primera de ellas es que
debe repetir el procedimiento
sancionatorio migratorio es decir que la
orden de expulsión queda suspendida
hasta que nuevamente se haga el
procedimiento con garantizando pues que
se para que se cumplan las medidas del
debido proceso que se tenga en cuenta la
situación particular de estas siete
personas y el impacto que una decisión
como ésta podría tener en la unidad
familiar y en los derechos de los niños
y niñas de los cuales ellos estas
personas pues son responsables o que
habían en colombia si una vez la fuerte
determina que no hay motivación para
haberse dado esta expulsión debe revocar
la decisión y además deberá ofrecer
disculpas públicas tanto la policía como
migración colombiana a las personas
afectadas por esta vulneración de
derechos y este jueves los presidentes
de eeuu joe biden y de rusia vladimir
putin sostendrán una llamada telefónica
para discutir entre otros temas la
creciente tensión en la frontera con
ucrania desde el gobierno estadounidense
señalan que byd en la insistirá a su
homólogo ruso que la unión americana
está preparada para responder ante una
eventual invasión a territorio ucraniano
la administración bailén continúa
participando en una extensa diplomacia
con nuestros aliados y socios europeos
consultando y coordinando un enfoque
común en respuesta a la concentración
militar de rusia en la frontera con
ucrania
el presidente bailén ha hablado con
líderes de toda europa y los
funcionarios de la administración baiden
se han comprometido multilateralmente
con la otan la unión europea y la ocs
los funcionarios también han mantenido
numerosas consultas con sus homólogos
incluidos los de los países del flanco
oriental de forma bilateral y en el de 9
así como con ucrania
rusia y belarús planean ejercicios
militares conjuntos entre febrero y
marzo de 2022 así lo confirmaron la
dimar putin y su homólogo alexander
lukachenko tras un encuentro en san
petersburgo la medida alimenta las
tensiones con la otan por una posible
invasión a rusia y por la crisis de
migrantes entre belarús y polonia
y hong kong vivió una jornada de
arrestos contra miembros y ex miembros
del medio de comunicación pero
democracia es tan tenues cientos de
policías allanaron la sede del portal de
noticias y los domicilios de varios
editores para investigar la supuesta
distribución de material sedicioso
veamos el informe de álvaro cordero
nuevamente las autoridades de hong kong
cargan contra un medio de comunicación
pro democrático unos 200 policías
allanaron la sede del diario están mls
para investigar un supuesto caso de
distribución de material silencioso y
detuvieron a seis miembros y ex miembros
del portal de noticias web entre ellos
al editor jefe en funciones patrick lahm
desde el medio sin embargo defienden su
trabajo
-esa news está haciendo reportajes
profesionales no hay duda al respecto
todo el mundo lo ve no importa qué
cargos se hayan hecho nada puede cambiar
esto aunque ya causa de todo no han
calcado bendigo a sisante durante varias
horas las autoridades incautaron
numeroso material periodístico para
negar su línea de investigación apunta
hacia una supuesta violación de la
polémica ley de seguridad nacional por
parte del medio que en los últimos años
se ha mostrado como uno de los más
críticos contra la presencia cada vez
mayor de bilin en la política hongkonesa
cualquiera que intenta hacer uso del
trabajo de los medios de comunicación
como herramienta para perseguir su
propósito político u otros intereses
contraviene la ley counter reigns trono
práctica del y ofensas particularmente
los delitos que ponen en riesgo la
seguridad nacional son los elementos
malvados que dañan a la libertad de
prensa
that's time air france grade a este es
un nuevo caso en el que se investiga y
detiene a miembros de un medio de
comunicación pro democrático dejan con
el cierre del periódico apple daily en
junio de este año marcó un antes y un
después en el ataque a la libertad de
prensa en la antigua colonia británica
hasta que este resumen informativo
quédense con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]